the supposed uh source that dr strange
and moses of madness will have wolverine
but it won't be
hugh jackman this seems plausible i am
going to give you my opinion on it real
quick uh but do me a favor please
subscribe to our notifications i am
doing this every day
uh let's talk about the strong
possibility of hugh jackman not
returning and or all i should say
although we do get wolverine uh most
likely as either an animated version or
we do have them recast i mean those are
the two options um we
will probably see either the
animated version possibly from the 1997
version
animated to disney plus uh sometime this
year or next year i believe i'm not
there is the other possibility of just
simply recasting him and this would most
likely be the wolverine that we do get
in the mcu uh which seems
ten times more plausible just because we
need the opportunity to introduce them
uh although
i doubt highly that there is already a
wolverine in the mcu they have yet to
introduce him i believe they will have
to bring him in from another universe
just for the sake of not giving him his
origin story
uh this may play out just like they did
with spider-man and not give us the
origin story and sort of have him
already
on the move doing his thing figuring out
his you know his abilities and whatnot
uh but not the technical origin story
because as we know i mean logan is
technically incredibly old as he does
not age so i'm not sure how they're
gonna do it um but it seems again
plausible that it is through another
universe
um what do you guys think about that do
you think that's the stronger
possibility
well i doubt that we'll see him play
charles xavier in future movies uh
outside of this one um i have a theory
that or at least i have read a theory
going around that uh
wanda will be
uh murdering the entire illuminati uh
and
going forward without any of the
characters that we see there
so let me know do you guys think
wolverine will be in another universe um
either animated or the wolverine that we
do get in the mcu i again my stronger
senses are going towards the
introduction of a new wolverine um but i
mean i don't know the mcu tends to
surprise us a lot so i'm gonna leave it
in their hands uh and they usually do a
great job so
uh we'll see what happens if you haven't
already please subscribe to our
notifications and i'll see you guys
tomorrow